[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Wednesday September 21st I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal
Spotify may be known as a place for
streaming music or podcasts but on
Tuesday the company launched a new
platform for audiobooks it includes more
than 300 000 titles from well-known
writers like Stephen King and Malcolm
Gladwell along with independent authors
and major publishers
the move sets up Spotify for two
potentially big fights one against
Amazon's audible platform which controls
nearly half of the audiobook space
the other is against Apple since Spotify
is asking people to use a browser for
purchases rather than using its app
joining us to discuss this is our music
industry reporter Ann Steele and before
we get started we should note that the
Wall Street journal's publisher Dow
Jones has a Content partnership with
spotify's gimlet media unit
hey Anne thanks for joining us thanks
for having me so let's start off with
why Spotify is doing this so this is
part of spotify's transition from being
a purely music focused Tech platform
into something bigger chief executive
Daniel Eck wants Spotify to be the
world's largest Audio company the place
consumers come for all of their audio
needs that started with music it's
expanded into podcasting and now the
company is trying to tackle audiobooks
in a bet that it can capture that
listening as well all right and I want
to talk about what this is going to mean
for the audiobook kind of industry and
what it's going to mean for Spotify
going forward but first I feel like we
really have to talk about what this
means for Spotify and its relationship
with apple because with this new service
it's kind of asking users to go around
in-store purchases and download using a
browser can you explain that a bit yeah
so Spotify on your phone is on an app
and if you're on an iOS device like an
iPhone that's something that comes
through Apple's App Store and so what
Spotify does for most of its monthly
subscriptions is to have people click
out of the app and put in their payment
information in a web browser and they do
that just because if a purchase is made
in app then Apple takes a commission on
that that can be up to 30 percent of a
purchase so what Spotify is doing with
audiobook payments is directing would-be
buyers outside of the app onto a web
browser to make that purchase and while
that does create a little bit of
friction and it makes for a more
clunkier buying process it means that
Apple won't be taking a cut of these
purchases what is that going to mean for
the relationship between Spotify and
apple though so Spotify has been one of
the companies actually fighting Apple
over its in-app purchase policies it's
been trying to get Regulators especially
in Europe on its side in this battle and
so this is just kind of another move on
spotify's part to get around having to
split their revenue with apple one thing
that made Spotify stand out when it
launched with music was its algorithm
you know its ability to connect
listeners with new music that they might
like how set up is it to do that with
audiobooks yeah so that algorithm took a
long time to work on and get to the
point where it is now so there is that
basis of knowledge there's everything
they know about how people listen to
music so there is the basis of the
algorithm to work off of but audiobooks
are different it is a different format
and they're going to have to learn so to
start they're only doing sort of
editorial recommendations so there's
human creators kind of surfacing hey
here are some great books we think a
general listener might be interested in
as people start downloading and
listening to audiobooks on Spotify
Spotify will get more information about
their listening habits and then be able
to build on that algorithm and then
eventually they want to be making great
recommendations just as they do for
music all right let's talk about what
this is going to mean for the audio book
Market I mean how challenging is it
going to be for Spotify to compete with
some of the companies some of the
leaders that are already in the audio
book space
so it's a challenge but Spotify has done
this before it came from behind with
podcasts Apple has been the dominant
player in podcasts forever since the
beginning of podcasts and Spotify has
really taken the market share very
seriously and very quickly
so this first move into audio books
they'll have 300 000 titles and they're
available on a paper download basis it's
pretty basic so this is what several
other platforms like Apple and Google
offer so there's nothing super new or
Innovative to start and it also doesn't
have a subscription plan which is what
market leader
Audible has which has nearly half of the
US audiobook Market
will this impact authors because Spotify
certainly Shook Up music and you
mentioned it shook up podcasts when it
got into those Industries I think it
remains to be seen and I think Spotify
is working with these Publishers and
with these authors and discussing all of
the options basically they've said
anything is on the table they're looking
at different business models so right
now they're starting with a la carte
pricing but maybe there'll be a
subscription down the road maybe there
will be ad supported listening like
Spotify already has with their free
music tier so these are all business
models that they're looking at and so
they are looking to innovate they do
want to disrupt this business but it's
going to take some time and some
experimentation and Gathering of data
and trying to figure out what listeners
want what authors need and what
Publishers need
how much is this gonna disrupt spotify's
existing businesses I mean is it gonna
throw off its music service at all yeah
so one of the questions that's been
raised as Spotify has gotten more into
podcasts in particular is is there
concern about taking away listening time
I.E someone is listening to a podcast
instead of streaming as much music and
what Executives have said is that the
addition of podcasts has actually
increased total consumption that users
have on the platform over time so users
are actually spending more time on
Spotify than they were previously and
they're thinking that will happen with
audiobooks as well
all right that's our reporter Anne
Steele thanks so much for joining us
Anne thanks so much
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing for more Tech stories check out
our website wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]